deliberadas el presidente ejecutivo de
la cadena estadounidense Fox news raper
mardoc reconoció este lunes bajo
juramento que algunos de los rostros más
populares de la principal cadena de
televisión del país respaldaron las
acusaciones de fraude del expresidente
Donald Trump en los comicios
presidenciales de 2020 lo hicieron para
mantener sus audiencias porque en
realidad sabían que las elecciones
fueron limpias el periódico de New York
Times publicó algunos de los mensajes
recogidos por la empresa denunciante
dominion System la empresa de conteo
electrónico que acusó a Fox de
difamación es una aguja difícil de
enhebrar pero realmente creo que muchos
de nuestro lado están siendo demagogos
imprudentes en este momento por supuesto
que lo son no los vamos a seguir en las
conversaciones privadas productores y
presentadores de renombre descartaban el
fraude la de software es Absurda
no creo que haya evidencia de fraude
electoral que influyó en las elecciones
sin embargo al aire los comentarios eran
radicalmente diferentes las elecciones
presidenciales del 2020 no fueron justas
ninguna persona honesta afirmaría lo
contrario el sistema estaba amañado a
muchos niveles para perjudicar un
candidato y beneficiar a otro dominion
demandó a la cadena en 2021 ante el
tribunal superior del estado de Delaware
y le exige 1600 millones de dólares por
la cobertura fraudulenta de los
resultados de las elecciones que sacaron
a Donald Trump de la casa